I got an electronic kit just in time for my
birthday, so in this project let’s open
it up and explore some of the things we can
do with LittleBits
To start this project, I’m using the CloudBit
starter kit, and the LittleBits space kit.
Opening it up, you can see all kinds of sensors,
switches and motors, including this little
power module, that hooks to a USB cable or
a 9 volt battery for power. Each little module
has magnets built into the ends so you can’t
connect them the wrong way. Instead, they
click themselves into position for you, making
simple circuit building a snap.
Now if we connect an LED to the end of the
button module, you can see in less than 5
seconds we’ve made a flashlight, that works
each time we press the button.
If we switch out the button with the sound
trigger module, we can turn on the light with
a snap or a clap.
Alright, let’s take this to the next level
with the CloudBit module. This little piece
snaps just about anything to the internet,
and you’ll see how it works in just a second.
Now if we bring in a remote trigger and this
owl puppet I found laying in the kids play
room, we can build a secret circuit to monitor
the kids.
First off, let’s cut a small hole in the
feathers of the puppet, just big enough to
expose the sensor.
This little device is going to let us know
when someone’s using a remote control. So
let’s snap some wires to either side of
the sensor, then snap it to the CloudBit module,
making this circuit wifi compatible.
I chose to snap my circuit to a mounting board
for convenience, and added a little bit of
duct tape, to keep the 9 volt battery beside
the circuit.
Our remote detector circuit is complete, and
now all we need to do is hide it. You can
see the sensor hides pretty well in the forehead,
and to get it all working, all we’ll need
to do is throw the power switch.
Alright, let’s go ahead and tuck everything
inside the puppet so it’s snug and secure,
and completely concealed.
Now I set this one beside the TV in our kids
playroom because our kids are in the habit
of sneaking up to watch TV after we’ve all
gone to bed. The difference now is that when
they press any button on the remote, the sensor
in the puppet triggers the circuit, and sends
a text message to my phone, letting us know
that some little body is watching TV.
I also found these could be used to detect
a thief. I made this circuit, in less than
10 seconds, by replacing the remote sensor
with a light sensor and an LED. When the light
sensor is covered, you can see the circuit
goes into standby mode, but reactivates when
light hits it again.
I tried taping this inside my safe, along
with a little note for any would-be intruder,
and if you watch carefully, you can see that
when the door closes, the LED shuts off and
the circuit switches to standby.
Now if anyone gets inside it lights up, scaring
away a potential thief, and sending an alert
that someone just opened your safe.
Now there are over a million circuit combinations
that you could make with these snap together
circuits, and for one final project, I tried
connecting a LittleBits AC switch inline with
a small space heater. The circuit uses an
infrared transmitter to activate the switch,
which can be done remotely by setting a few
simple commands on www.ifttt.com. So now instead
of heating an empty house all day, simply
send a text message on your way home from
work, to turn on the heater. This way you’ll
save energy, and and still come home, to a
nice warm room.
Well there are a few projects I tried with
a LittleBits electronics kit, to solve some
everyday challenges, and learn more about
electronics in the process. Well that’s
it for now. If you liked this project, perhaps
you’ll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com